hello everybody  and welcome to the very first ever World  Cup live stream from the flagrant crew  it's your boy schultzy if you don't know  which team we riding hard for then you  gotta be blind okay it's USA all [ __ ]  day we got the greats in the building Mr  Rogers Steve Rogers Captain America we  got top gun Maverick we got Betsy Ross  we got Lady Liberty we got Uncle Sam  we're coming to collect them taxes I ran  okay I don't hear nothing and we got  Abba representing Canada okay  what what the shout out to the  revolution no well the revolution yes  shout out to the revolution the women  fighting shout out to the women fighting  show your hair or don't do whatever the  [ __ ] you want